>>Student: Right now we're hiking
out to the flow like we said earlier,
and we brought our equipment with us,
our GPS, Global Positioning System,
and we're going to go track the
outside perimeter of the flow
that we measured yesterday.
So okay..
>>Narrator: These young explorers are
studying fresh lava flows on Hawaii,
and broadcasting their
observations via satellite
to schools around the world.
>>Student: And we're
studying lava flows.
>>Narrator: This ambitious
expedition is the culmination
of this year's JASON Project,
a comprehensive project-based
learning program developed
by Doctor Bob Ballard, the explorer
who found the wreck of the Titanic.
>>Robert: Why don't you
say, "Hi," to everyone?
>>Student: Hi, everybody.
>>Robert: I came back
from that expedition.
There were 16,000 letters
waiting for me,
and they all basically
said the same thing.
You know, what do I have
to do to do what you do?
Well the answer is simple.
You go to college, you
study physics for ten years,
it's a slam-dunk after that.
But the kids were not
making the connection
between the scientific adventure
I was having and the dues I had
to pay to live that adventure.
>>Narrator: Begun in 1989, the
JASON Project now reaches more
than five million fourth through
eighth graders around the world.
>>Robert: The idea is this: that they
will study a pretty tough curriculum
with science, and chemistry,
math and physics, and biology
and social sciences as well.
And then at the culmination
of their studies,
we'll do an expedition live for them.
>>And we'll be going up to the
crater up at Kilauea, up on the rim.
>>Sometimes we'll go
in the rainforest,
sometimes we'll go beneath
the sea, sometimes we'll go
into outer space, doesn't matter.
Wherever there's action in science.
And then we use this
technology of tele-presence
to then transport them
on the expedition.
>>Student: Get the
camera, look at that.
>>Student: Wow, look at that.
>>Student: Back up, back
up, back up, back up.
>>Robert: We also have our Argonaut
programs, and these are kids
that actually go on
the expedition with us,
and they're sort of our ambassadors.
Kids listen to kids, so we like to
integrate them into the program.
>>Student: We now have
what we call a lava dogs
down on the actual active lava
flow, and right now it's quite..
>>Gwendolyn: This for us helps
close that digital divide
because our students may not have all
the resources to be able to travel
to these different
locations, you know?
At least they have that
understanding of the world.
We bring it right here
using the technology.
>>Narrator: Gwendolyn Faulkner
and Beverly Battle have
seen the positive impact
of project-based learning
programs like the JASON Project
on their students at Washington
D.C.'s Harriet Tubman School.
>>Beverly: And that was showing
how birds adapt to their habitats
or their environments
by using their beaks.
On your tables, you have been
given a set of tweezers, straw,
a spoon, and a clothespin.
And also you have some food sources.
>>I have a population of
students who are very diverse.
Students who are African-American,
Hispanic, and Asian,
and a lot of those students come
to us not equipped with the skills
that some of our counterparts
in the city may have.
>>And see how much you can
pick up with your beak.
>>Their skills have
strengthened in reading, in math,
in all subject areas as
a result of participating
in project-based learning.
>>Student: This is
how much we picked up,
and this is how much we have left.
>>Beverly: All right.
>>Student: We get to interact more
with each other, with the teacher.
It's more fun.
>>Beverly: One of my Hispanic
students spoke very little English
when he came to me in September.
And his involvement in project-based
learning has made him come
out of his shell.
He's eager to do whatever
you want him to do.
He loves getting on the computer.
He is no longer the shy
student who did not want
to talk when I called on him.
Now he's eager to answer
it all the time.
>>What were they doing?
>>Student: They wanted to see how
one bug on the surface is different
to the same bug in the lava too.
>>Beverly: Okay, good, very good.
>>Narrator: In addition
to the interdisciplinary curriculum
materials, there's an opportunity
for students to publish
their journals and chat live
with scientists on the web.
>>Gwendolyn: So kids can actually
actively engage with scientists,
asking them their real-life
questions,
and getting almost an
immediate response back.
So it opens up the doors of
opportunity, and that's what
that technology will
allow us to do here.
>>Beverly: Now we're going
to show how volcanoes erupt.
>>Our students have a
very short attention span,
so we have to constantly
think of ideas
which to keep them busy,
to keep them involved.
>>When she puts it in, close it.
>>Student: Close it.
>>Beverly: Quickly
[Gasps and laughter].
>>Beverly: It gives you a lift when
you see the children are learning.
You see on their faces what happens
during an experiment like we did
in the classroom with the explosion
of the Alka-Seltzer in the film can.
You know, they don't
see this every day.
>>How would that compare
to a volcano erupting?
>>Student: it probably-- with enough
pressure get in it, it'll pop.
>>Beverly: All right, where
would that pressure come from?
>>Student: The center.
>>Beverly: The center of what?
>>Student: The earth.
>>Beverly: All right.
>>For them to learn something from
that, and to connect that knowledge,
that gives me a lift,
and it makes me know
that I'm having successes
in my classroom.
And a teacher wants to have success.